Jesse are the twins are in the Roblox
world yeah but I'm going to just get
them tickets to The Met for Christmas
super well and Dana I am judging these
parents okay I'm judging them harshly
judge you probably would agree legally
you can charge these parents with child
abuse neglect at best neglect this is
they're either cheap or liberal the
whole point of Christmas morning is the
physical unwrapping of the gifts yeah
it's The Ripping of the wrapping paper
the surprise on their faces the creation
of the piles that's the experience of it
you don't want to get an experience you
want to experience the experience of
unwrapping a physical gift right and any
parent that doesn't understand that is
stupid and so we're going to bring them
up on some serious charges judge what
about unwrapping a tie like this beauty
this was from our gift exchange from the
or taping of the five special this is a
gut filled tie do hope I'm not
yeah adding to his bank account by
having this but I I wear it proudly and
it looks good the prime time yeah the
prime time one we're working on this
judge what are you getting your grandson
uh well first of all I want to say a few
things about Christmas gifts I remember
Christmas Eve as being the worst night
of the year you know why after the kids
went to bed no after oh I did all the
cooking that's true I was exhausted but
after that the kids went to bed we had
to put together the games the the Train
the the whatever it was yes and all
night long so that we could put it in
front of the Christmas tree in the
morning but you know sometimes I think
that we buy things for our kids that are
so over the top and so ridiculous
because it's almost about like
self-guilt like if we're not as good a
parent if we don't spend that much money
so I kind of look at this a different
way Jesse kind of look at it as you know
maybe we've kind of overdone some stuff
maybe a little educational stuff maybe
this that but obviously put the boxes in
the middle of it but but you know kids
are happy you know my grandson in the
end will probably get a pot out of the
cabinet and play with it but no I got
them all kinds of things well that is
true you can spend hundreds of dollars
on these expensive gifts and then you
give the kid like a stick or like a ball
for two dollars and they love it yeah
that's all you need we these I thought
these parents were my parents were a lot
more harsh than these ones there this
woman who wrote the article said that
she takes the kids skiing to Big Bear or
goes to Disney World we didn't have
Disney World
yeah I know do I used to beg to go to
Disney World my dad would say look in
the view Master it's your Disney World
discs you remember the Viewmaster yes
would look at the pictures at Disney
world that's all I had as a kid and I
used to give my kids this is the best
gift whenever I was on the road my hotel
keys I would come home and I'd give each
a credit card I'd say here's a credit
card and they would play you know with
the credit card and they would play
pretended checking and you're like I'll
need two keys yeah no I just walk out of
the hotel with my two keys and I would
give them to my kids and it was a great
gift good idea he's a mean dad though
yeah yeah it works in a good way it
works I mean I had when I was a kid I
remember my teacher in second grade said
you can bring in for show and tell one
gift but only one gift and all the kids
were like only one and I was like I only
got one